ok stellt euch eine großstadt vor ohne
abgase hier eingelagert und dahingesagt
das wäre möglich
mit solarautos ich hab mal wieder sagt
losgeschickt das ist unsere rasende
reporterin oder auch wie er sie nennt
unserem ein outing oder mein abstand
frau ich war in belgien bei der european
solar challenge dass es quasi die em für
solar autos und da habe ich sogar ein
solarauto unfall überlebt ich brauch so
gebraucht
und da habe ich sogar ein solarauto
unfall überlebt dazu kommen wir auch
gleich noch aber erstmal wie
funktionieren solarautos eigentlich wer
sind die menschen die diese autos bauen
und ist es wirklich nachhaltig also
macht es euch gemütlich wir schauen uns
heute an wie die zukunft auf unsere
straßen aussieht
[Musik]
die european solar challenge ist kein
gewöhnliches rennen erstens die autos
und solarautos und zweitens das rennen
dauert ganze 24 stunden es kommt also
nicht darauf an wer als erstes über die
ziellinie fährt sondern wer die meisten
kilometer schafft und dafür kommen die
leute auch nicht nur aus europa sondern
aus der ganzen welt zusammen und alle
haben ihre autos dabei bzw
die teile ihrer autos und tage vorher
sind alle damit beschäftigt die autos
zusammenzubauen und alles vorzubereiten
bzw sind die bochumer sogar mit manchen
ihre autos direkt über die autobahn hin
gefahren das war dann natürlich ein
riesen spektakel weil ich mein ich habe
vorher auch an diesen spacey auto
gesehen das heißt die leute machen dann
auch fotos und so dass teilweise sogar
ein bisschen gefährlich aber es sind ja
alle sichern
kommen wir ins auto war dieses ganz
flache oder so einfältig tennis mit der
anreise allein war es aber leider noch
nicht getan die leute hatten ford noch
so viel zu tun mit reparaturen und
zusammen basteln und so weiter dass sie
wirklich direkt neben der rennstrecke so
einen campingplatz für alle teilnehmer
hatten damit sie ganz nah an ihren autos
waren also 11 engineering camp find ich
gut ihr seid ihr hier irgendwie nen
richtig durch gemixt das team studiert
hier alle das gleiche oder kommt ihr es
ist so eine art ag und jeder kann
mitmachen also studier bei weitem nicht
alle das gleiche an unserer hochschule
gibt es verschiedene fachbereiche und
irgendwie sind annähernd alle vertreten
wir haben auch mittlerweile mehrere
hochschulen dabei also auch eine design
hochschule aber auch medienleute genauso
wie wir wirtschaftler haben und wir
sagen auch immer man muss nicht wirklich
was können nur die motivation mitbringen
den rest bringen bei als man muss jetzt
keine großen erfahrungen oder speziell
studiert haben können auf jeden fall wer
spaß hat soll mitmachen und dann finden
wir genügend aufgabe das ist übrigens
christian von der hochschule bochum und
seine aufgabe ist es die abläufe zu
koordinieren
also dass etwas womit man nicht rechnet
passieren wird das ist eigentlich recht
sicher
wir sind am abend vorher an dieser
rennstrecke angekommen erzählt denken
alle ich könnte auch das bauen
das kann jeder okay da wird noch um
gebastelt wurden noch autos probe
gefahren und sachen boden teilweise noch
offenen letzten drücker repariert also
geschlafen haben die leute da er wenig
hier ein solo unterwegs moment warum
fahren solarautos eigentlich auch nachts
alle autos hier sind auch elektroautos
das heißt sie fahren auf batterie ist
ein elektroauto was die solarzellen als
ich seine art range extender wenn man so
will
dabei hat das quasi den tank während der
fahrt wieder befüllen kann sind übrigens
dieselben batterien wie in unseren
handys oder laptops nämlich lithium
ionen batterie die bestehend aus zwei
elektroden die positive elektrode
besteht aus einer lithium metall
verbindung zum beispiel lithium kobalt
oxid die negative elektrode besteht aus
graphit dass man neuerdings mit
schreiben soll
dass sie komisch aus egal zwischen den
elektroden ist eine leitende flüssigkeit
der elektrolyt durch den eltern können
sich geladene teilchen zum beispiel
lithium ionen gewesen wenn ich die
batterien laden sammeln sich elektronen
im graphit und lithium ionen aus dem
lithium kobalt oxid gesellen sich dazu
in der chemischen reaktion namens
reduktion verbinden sich lithium ionen
und elektronen zu lithium atome benutzt
man die batterie kehrt sich die
chemische reaktion um aus reduktion wird
oxidation dabei werden wieder elektronen
frei die dann der strom das auto bevor
während die lithium ionen wieder an den
fluss po zurückkehren nachts fahren die
autos also auf batterie damit für die ja
nicht aufbrauchen er für natürlich
entsprechend fahren
aber sind wir doch das spannende an dem
24 stunden rennen weil wir eben nur die
hälfte davon auch ohne lehrer morgens
wurde erst mal in großer runde gemeinsam
auf dem campingplatz gefrühstückt ist
auch ganz wichtig für die leute aus den
zelten gebrochen sind mega durch mich so
hallo ich halte jetzt eine kamera in
denn gesicht auf der rennstrecke selbst
war das chaos groß da wurde noch um
geschraubt reifen wurden gewechselt
sachen wurden noch neu programmiert und
auseinandergenommen und leute lagen auch
unter autos und haben sachen auf den
letzten drücker gerade gerückt und dann
ging es plötzlich auch schon los
tatsächlich habe ich mir diesen staats
und bisschen spektakulärer vorgestellt
das ist ja so ein bisschen langsam an
geräumt weil man sich da alles
versammelt und dann sind wir dahingehend
den autos und ich sondern erst mal so
groß gedruckt
aber ist ja eigentlich auch logisch ich
meine die müssen 24 stunden dadurch
fahren macht keinen sinn da am anfang
direkt die ganze energie rauszuhauen und
es ist ein bisschen ironisch mal
wirklich ungefähr genau mit dem
staatsschutz hat es angefangen zu regnen
und es hat das auch einfach nicht mehr
aufgehört aber ich habe gelernt
solarzellen funktionieren auch bei regen
für solarzellen braucht man materialien
die man halbleiter nennt silizium wäre
so ein material silizium leitet strom so
halb halt um zu verstehen wie man strom
halb leiten kann lasst uns erst mal
anschauen welche stoffe strom leiten und
welche strom nicht leid zu jetzt wird es
ein bisschen chemische stoffe sind ja
aus atomen aufgebaut und alle atome
haben einen kern umhüllt von elektronen
nehmen wir mal an metallen
das ist so aufgebaut ist besteht
natürlich aus metall atomen aber diese
metallatome die äußeren elektronen davon
die sind nicht fest gebunden sondern die
können sich frei in dem ganzen metall
herum bewegen
man nennt das auch elektronen gas
deshalb leitet eine strom der er nichts
anderes ist als elektronen doch bei
kohlenstoff zum beispiel sitzen die
elektronen in den bindungen fest sie
sind nicht beweglich und deswegen leitet
kohle auch keinen strom zu halbleiter
wie zum beispiel silizium die können
strom leiten oder auch nicht das ist zum
beispiel abhängig von der temperatur
aber man kann die leitfähigkeit von
silizium auch gezielt einstellen indem
man das silizium mit einer krise eines
anderen elements würzt wenn man in einen
silizium gitter hier und da ein paar
phosphor atome einbaut bekommt man
dadurch eine art dünnes elektronen gas
jedes phosphor atom hat ein elektron
mehr als silizium und diese
überflüssigen elektronen die braucht man
nicht wird die bindungen die können sich
da dessen einfach frei bewegen und
dieses würzen mit phosphor nennt man
negative dotierung man kann aber auch
positiv notieren indem man statt ein
paar phosphor thome ein paar bohr atome
nimmt wo hat nämlich ein elektron
weniger als silizium so entstehen
elektronen löcher die man im
perfekt als positive ladung verstehen
kann positiv dotiertes edition ist also
ein leiter für positive ladungen damit
haben wir jetzt schon die basics für
eine solarzelle eine solarzelle ist
folgendermaßen aufgebaut die nehmen
einen silizium kristall bei dem die eine
hälfte negativ die andere hälfte positiv
dotiert ist
an der übergangs schicht passiert
folgendes die negativen elektronen und
die positiven löcher re kombinieren und
wünschen sich gegenseitig aus wenn man
so will
wo die negativen elektronen verschwinden
bleibt eine positive ladung zurück und
die positiven löcher verschwinden bleibt
eine negative lagen zurück und so
bekommen wir eine elektrische spannung
genau wie bei der batterie und ihren
plus und minuspol und jetzt kommt's
sonnenlicht mit einer energie die diese
elektronen noch paare wieder trennen
kann entstehen wieder elektronen und
löcher die elektronen werden abgefangen
und als strom durch das auto geleitet
und re kombiniere am ende wieder mit
ihren löchern
jetzt sind wir hier bei der european
solar challenge die world solar
challenge findet immer in australien
statt und da ist die sonne ziemlich
ordentlich unterstützung
er konnte in australien 600 kilometer
reine batterieleistung
und wenn man mit die solarzellen
komplett nutzt sein bis zu 1000
kilometern also ich persönlich finde die
vorstellung so cool dass wir vielleicht
in ein paar jahren schon abgasfrei durch
die städte fahren können aber ich habe
mich gefragt ob die herstellung der
solarzellen und der batterien wirklich
so nachhaltig sind wie man denkt in der
herstellungs- phase ist ein e auto oder
besonders ein solarauto sehr
energieintensiv im verbrauch hinterher
sind wir sehr emissionsarm die jungs und
mädels haben wir erklärt dass sie für
ihre autos verschiedene solarzellen
benutzen
es gibt grundsätzlich zwei arten von
solarzellen einmal silizium und einmal
galliumarsenid siliziumzellen sind auf
den hausdächern verbaut
die sind wesentlich umwelt schonen
allerdings ist galliumarsenid wesentlich
effizienter an da muss man halt abwägen
muss an so viel gedacht werden an das
material wo das herkommt wie das
produziert wird da ist echt so eine
riesen kette an sachen dahinter die man
echt noch berücksichtigen muss diese
batterie herstellung der wird
unglaublich viel energie für verwendet
je nachdem welche batteriezelle wir
verwenden werden wie 7 bis 8000 diese
kleinen rom zählen verbauen und das sind
natürlich massenhaft so dass ich so eine
kleine autobatterie sondern das ist so
eine moschee liegt über 60 club also
unsere batterien nehmen ein in unserer
co2 bilanz auf einen großen teil 1
zum beispiel muss man auch schauen wo
der strom mit dem man die batterien
belädt herkommt und auch was mit dem
strom den man braucht um die autos
herzustellen beispiel in australien
kommt sehr viel strom noch aus
braunkohle ist also sehr emissions-
stark da wäre es nachhaltige das ganze
nach skandinavien zu verlegen wo vieles
aus wasserkraft kommt für das bochumer
team ist jedenfalls klar sie müssen die
ganze kette beziehungsweise diese ganzen
vernetzungen im auge behalten um
wirklich nachhaltige lösungen zu
schaffen zb achten sie auch auf
nachhaltige rohstoffe wie zum beispiel
naturfasern holz ananas leder
das ist eine gute frage was auch noch
ein problem ist dass man die solarzellen
ist hier sehr empfindlich sind man kann
ihn nicht anfassen
du hast ja bestimmt auch gemerkt das ist
bei einem handelsüblichen auto einfach
nicht praktisch weil die werden dreckig
da kommt tage darauf kommt regen drauf
und ich glaube wenn dieser schritt
überwunden ist zum einen dieser schritt
und zum anderen dass sie ein bisschen
umweltfreundlicher produziert werden
können ich glaube dann sind wir ganz
schnell bei solar autos also kriegen
ich glaube schon das ist quatsch jetzt
von heute auf morgen alle verbrenner
durch elektroautos setzen aber ein
schritt weisungen stieg und vor allem
jetzt in den großstädten dass er sich so
etwas wie den zweitwagen den ja einige
haushalte haben schon mal auszutauschen
das ist durchaus machbar wenn man sich
einfach mal den die verfügbarkeit von
fossilen brennstoffen und den verbrauch
dieser anguckt jetzt kann man sich auf
ein blatt papier selber aufmalen da
braucht man gar kein großer mathematiker
für sein um irgendwann so ein break even
point zu finden und man sagt okay und
newsmax kind auf jeden fall noch viel zu
tun aber das tun sie
und sie haben spaß dabei ist coole ist
ja die stimmung vor ort das ist jetzt
kein totaler konkurrenzkampf sondern
eher im gegenteil da ist da findet
wissenschaftliche austausch statt und
man leiht sich eben wir gegenseitig
ersatzteile die mehrere tausend euro
kosten und alle haben irgendwie spaß und
arbeiten zusammen an einer sache obwohl
es an verschiedenen autos ist aber alle
wollen halt irgendwie ein cooles
endprodukt und das war echt spannend ja
zu sehen
wir durften sogar ein paar runden mit
fahren wegen des regens gab es sogar
einen kleinen zwischenfall wir sind
nämlich glaube ich so 50 oder solange
düst und in der kurve sind wir einfach
von der fahrbahn abgekommen plötzlich
dreht sich das ding ohne vorwarnung und
auf einmal stehen wieder auf diesen
seitenstreifen würde ich mir so viel
dachte ich aber auch scheiße die armen
die haben hier so viel arbeit
reingesteckt und ich dachte das ding wir
halt kaputt und dann war erstmal kurz
stille und dann sind die einfach
weitergefahren und diese passiert schon
mal haben dann kurz ganz locker per funk
durchgegeben dass sie da ein bisschen
was verloren haben oder so
[Musik]
und da habe ich sogar ein solarauto und
volk überlebt also sagte du hast deine
deinem namen als landfrau matips dann
vor alle ehre gemacht und vielen dank
dafür und weil wir noch vorschläge habt
was sagt als nächstes in action machen
kann dann schreibe es in die kommentare
unter dem hashtag stand es nicht ernst
hashtags tanzabend aber heizstab noch
nicht weggehen wir haben nämlich in der
end karte noch eine abstimmung für euch
nach unserem video über schlafmangel gab
es sehr viele fragen von euch zu schlaff
deswegen gibt es nächste woche ein video
zu dem thema online versus lerchen also
frühaufsteher erst spät aufstehe und
auch so spät lange wach bleibe für
dieses video bitte ich euch hier oben
abzustimmen zweimal erstens was seid ihr
wollen oder lesen seit ihr tag oder
nacht menschen und was glaubt ihr was
ich will
die auflösung gibt es nächsten montag
bis dahin bleibt sicher